astonishing it's astonishing your
cover's blown and you can't make little
dick jokes anymore dude my dick is pure
I believe that no my dick is Magic I
believe that too my dick is like it's
small but it's average but it's not
small don't do that
but it's but don't do whatever you're
doing don't do that pure it's pure is it
pure it's what's it taste like
the time where it did for a couple years
there it did not taste that great years
Bobby
ears it tasted oh
it's not Aquafina look at me in the iron
say it but you know exactly why it
tasted that way for years what like [ __ ]
not not [ __ ] what but something similar
to a foot okay that's not true that's
not [ __ ] true and I'm tired of your
[ __ ] lies
she's saying this makes no [ __ ]
logical sense she's saying I have foot
fungi
okay
I had a foot fungi right my left foot
smelled ridiculous she's claiming that
it ventured up to my dick yeah yeah and
my dick smells like you got jumping
fungus dude
that's a good video game 80s video game
yeah you may you may want to prepare
yourself to cut this out but I'm gonna
defend myself real quick oh I I can
already I already know what you're gonna
say exactly the truth oh yeah say it and
cut it out Bobby she'll just bleep it
this dirty [ __ ] admitted
[Laughter]
all right cut cut it out that stays in
you play a 30-second sensor beep
I don't know why I'm not shy
so you really are what you eat huh
can you cut in there yeah can you cut
him yeah we can cut in there you are
what so you guys missed something great
I don't want to talk I don't want to
talk about my penis I don't want to talk
about penis anymore but I want to say
this all right that it is nice women
like it yeah right yeah and it's pure
and that's all I want to say that's
right no complaints never have headaches
and it's medium right medium medium this
is the dynamic I wanted to see by the
way what just you two I I find it
fascinating that you had been in a
relationship and you you you pretend
like everything civil in a professional
setting but let's be honest with you
there's a little something going on is
it like resentment is it well I never
noticed that maybe the Envy what is that
yeah I love nothing going on right there
yeah
okay stop saying no that stays in please
that's the hate in my heart
that's what it is yeah yeah we're not
talking about your [ __ ] anymore in my
dick all right because they've done it
right they've met
welcome back to the country or our
country you know what I mean dude dude
something about you Bobby just makes
everyone want to talk about the generals
no I know let's stop for a second right
I don't want to talk about my genitals
anymore because it's like it's older
right it's it works and it's um it's
likable very likable right I'll say for
51
no I am 51 years old liar no I'm 27. and
yeah well what the [ __ ] look at this guy
okay hold up the king of the world at
27. oh [ __ ] ing way you're 51. yeah dude